there is a a hilarious report from axios
now it's not actually comedy
it's it's serious but it's hilarious in
what it's suggesting
and the axios report claims that donald
trump is actually getting ready
to restart those depraved he calls them
maga rallies
i call them corona rallies and it's all
to keep the fight going against supposed
voter fraud that he claims
allow joe biden to steal the election
from him as of right now
these are all baseless claims without
any evidence
so the plan as per axios is that the
trump team
will announce recounts in specific
states
and then they will hold rallies in those
states and the idea will be to fly in
and really raise money for the recounts
which are expensive
and also try to kind of build public
support for those recounts and the idea
that these states were fraudulently
stolen from donald trump now as i told
you yesterday
in the story about trump's last scam if
you look at the fine print of the
fundraising that donald trump is doing i
know that if you watched yesterday's
show you know this but i want to repeat
it
if you look at the fine print of trump's
fundraising for so-called recounts and
fighting fraud
the fine print is 50 of of every dollar
you donate not you but the people who
would be dumb enough to do it
50 of every dollar donated goes not to
fund the recounts whoa sorry i hit my
mic they're getting a little too excited
but half the money goes to paying off
donald trump's campaign debt
so it's sort of like the final scam
on the tail end of what has been four
years of a scam presidency
and the key states that they're looking
at are reportedly georgia arizona and
pennsylvania
now there have been reports that team
trump is not all on the same page about
this like for example
we got a report two days ago that rudy
giuliani
wants trump to do rallies but that
trump's chief of staff mark meadows
and son-in-law jared kushner want trump
to concede
but then there was a conflicting report
that jared kushner actually wants trump
to do rallies and mark meadows said
something like
con concession isn't even in our
vocabulary
we'll eventually know the truth
according to this axios report
everybody's on the same page and they
plan to get trump re-elected who
the hell knows but if trump does do
these rallies
it would not only be a scam but it would
be
extra irresponsible given coronavirus
you're not even running for anything at
this point like
we know that the rallies have been
responsible for hundreds and likely even
thousands of deaths
while trump was running a campaign
at least he could say i have to win
for the good of the country i believe
him winning would have been bad
and we know because joe biden did it
that you can campaign safely
but at least he had something he was
running for this
is now really just bottom of the barrel
trash like this is how you destroy a
country he's not only refusing to
concede which is not a legal issue
concession is merely a formality but it
makes him look foolish and it's bad for
the country
but he's reportedly going to try to
re-litigate the election
through campaign-style rallies the likes
of which were
already irresponsible due to the
pandemic before the election
now if you look at the court judgment so
far
to figure out does he have a shot here
the court judgments so far
about voter fraud have gone universally
against trump's campaign
all of them saying there's nothing here
to move forward on there's just
there's no there there but this now
these rallies would be to get to the
court of public opinion get crowds of
people
where the focus is no longer vote for me
on election day
the focus is we need money to beat joe
biden with lawsuits
so if the reports were true that jared
kushner and melania were telling trump
to concede
it seems that those efforts have failed
and we also shouldn't understate the
impact
of these possible rallies on trump's ego
which at the end of the day that's
really a huge role in what trump decides
to do
each day and a big piece of doing these
rallies would be ego and nothing else
will republican senators even speak up
and call trump out
if he does this or are they going to
remain quiet because understand that as
of just a few hours ago
only four republican senators have even
acknowledged that joe biden won and that
donald trump lost
those are most recently susan collins
and
we had mitt romney say biden won we had
lisa murkowski say it we had been sass
say it it is absolutely pathetic and
we're going to follow
whether these rallies become a reality
and whether someone is able to talk
donald trump out of it because
ultimately that's what this may come
down to
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 percent off lucy is a company founded
by cal
tech scientists with only one mission
which is to help
people quit smoking and vaping
by offering a clean affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice flavor
lucy is affordable it'll ship right to
your door you don't have to go out to
the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's the year 2020. it's time to throw
the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape and lucy can
make it easier
you'll find a ton of excellent reviews
online from countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.com i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get
twenty percent off when you use the
coupon code pacman
and just a quick disclaimer i'm required
to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical